it was the best of times it was the
worst of times it was the age of make
America great again it was the age of
America was never really great
it was the election season of hope it
was the election season of despair are
we heading toward a civil war the
Atlantic Monthly and many other outlets
and people think America is headed for
Civil War the Atlantic is dedicating its
entire December issue to how that Civil
War might be avoided we will examine how
to bring our country back from the brink
then a Canadian broadcaster loses his
job for calling on his countrymen to
honor their veterans honoring veterans
is now apparently racist Democratic
senator mazie Hirono admits that global
warming is a religion and americans warm
up to the idea of men beating women at
sports all that and much more I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Nolt show
[Music]
what schizophrenic times we live in we
live in the age of me too hyper feminism
we live in the age of men beating women
at sports and when they can't do
anything about it we live in make
America great again the height of
patriotism most patriotic we've seen
ourselves in a long time we live in an
era where we can't even celebrate our
nation's history where we're ripping
down statues of George Washington and
the people who founded this country
where we hate ourselves as a country
where we're Canadian broadcasters are
getting fired for honoring veterans I
know Canada's not America but it is
America's hat and Washington's greatest
mistake so you know I think it's kind of
lumped in very similar culture here
we'll get to all of that because a lot
of people have called our moment a cold
Civil War I have refrained from using
that kind of language and friends of
mine have used it Dennis Prager uses it
a lot other guys were very sharp guys
I've refrained I felt it was a little
hyperbolic but now it is getting real
why is it getting real how is our
division deepened so much that I'm
pretty much willing to use the term
because Ann Coulter is calling for
Donald Trump to get out of the White
House Ann Coulter whom I love tweet it
out okay that does it I give up they can
stay referring to Daka illegal aliens
you must go that was to president Trump
that was in response to a Trump tweet
where he said quote many of the people
in Dhaka no longer very young are far
from angels some are very tough hardened
criminals President Obama said he had no
legal right to sign the order but would
anyway if Supreme Court remedies with an
overturn of daca a deal will be made
with Dems for them to stay so he's
saying look this is a mess I inherited
this mess on daca
the whole concept of the dreamers is
obviously political propaganda but if
the supreme court overturns daca which
it may well do right now then we'll get
a deal and we'll let the dreamers stay
Ann Ann Coulter says it's over I feel
like a true child of divorce if Ann
Coulter and Donald Trump are fighting I
hate it I don't want them to fight but
the divisions are real and it's not just
an Coulter and Donald Trump it's it's
not
even just on the issue of immigration
Donald Trump jr. was heckled the other
night at UCLA at his own event not by
the left but by very very far-right
activists
San Francisco is now officially turning
one of America's great cities into a
giant very expensive outhouse even as
word like the richest country ever on
the face of the earth even as San
Francisco is one of the richest cities
ever to exist and has as far as I can
tell the highest real estate prices in
the whole country you've also got that
once great city once Golden City turned
into an outhouse Americans are now
warming up according to polling two men
beating women at sports two men saying
that they can be women to men
disadvantaged disadvantaging women and
this Canadian broadcaster is now fired
for honoring veterans obviously that's
across the border in Canada we're seeing
many similar things in the United States
things have gotten completely insane we
are divided over ideology were divided
over race were divided over religion
were divided over even basic scientific
facts and people are throwing out a
whole lot of ideas as to how we can
bridge that divide but I think I've got
the best answer to that so we'll get to
that in a second first I want to thank
our friends over at zip recruiter zip
recruiter is the only way to hire hiring
can be a slow arduous annoying process
cafe au tour is co Odilon miss quits
needed to hire a director of coffee for
his organic coffee company he was having
trouble finding qualified applicants so
what did he do
switched to zip recruiter zip recruiter
does not just depend on candidates
finding you it finds the candidates for
you zip recruiters technology identifies
people with the right experience and
invites them to apply to your job so
it's not just throwing spaghetti at the
wall it's actually going out there
finding you those candidates so that you
get qualified candidates fast dylan
posted his job on zip recruiter he said
he was impressed by how quickly he had
candidates apply he then used
supercruise candidate rating feature so
he filters through all those applicants
he could focus on the best applicants
and that's how Dylan found his new
director of coffee in just a few days it
just saves time it's just a better
way to do it not just like those old job
boards where you're hoping anything
sticks it goes that it finds the
candidates time is money especially when
you're trying to grow your business with
results like that it's no wonder that
four out of five employers who post on
zip recruiter get a quality candidate
within the first day and it is really
really important to find those
candidates quickly I've seen it happen
at a lot of companies where you need to
hire a lot of people and it just drags
on and on and on and that can really
thwart the growth of your business in
some ways it can really really stop it
all together see why zip recruiter is
effective for businesses of all sizes
tricep recruiter for free at our web
address sip recruiter comm slash Knowles
Canada wles zip recruiter dot-com slash
Knowles kena wles what is it zip
recruiter comm slash Knowles zip
recruiter is the smartest way to hire so
America is really divided in these
extremely schizophrenic times where on
the one hand everything looks like it's
going so great and yet people are losing
their minds so how are we going to
bridge the divide in America a lot of
very stupid answers and nobody's
focusing on the real answer some people
are calling for moderation from
conservatives they're always calling for
moderation from conservatives you know
if even conservatives are calling for
moderation from conservatives if only
those conservatives would just lay down
and let the left run roughshod over the
entire culture then we could all get
along yeah I don't think so some people
are calling from moderation for leftists
good luck good luck buddy I'll see how
that's going some people are calling for
a return to the founding of the country
we just would regain that spirit of 1776
if we would just live like we lived 250
years ago then we could reunite the
country some people on very specific
policy are calling for an end to all
immigration because they see immigration
is this hot-button issue is the central
issue of the Donald Trump campaign it's
a central issue of the fights that we're
having right now over the southern
border over Dhaka
at the Supreme Court even on the right
some are calling for greater government
involvement in social questions it's
those social questions it's the role of
the state because you can say okay
you've got this pie in
Skai philosophy what are you actually
gonna do are you gonna get the
government more involved in social
policy or are you going to try to get
the government to back away and not have
anything to say about social policy
that's the kind of debate you saw with
so Rob Amari and David French David
French ISM as it's called do you want
the government to start making some
value claims saying this thing is better
than this thing and government policies
are going to be geared toward virtue or
are we going to say that the government
needs to totally back out of these
issues you can't legislate morality
you've just got to let people live as
they're going to live I've come what may
that's the best way to preserve a good
society let's go through each one of
these because I think they're all pretty
flawed moderation from conservatives is
absurd we've moderated we've moderated
so much we nominated John McCain we
nominated Mitt Romney you can't moderate
any more than that I mean listen to just
the issue of the dreamers which got Ann
Coulter all upset and President Trump
when President Trump was running for
office and early in his administration
he said we need to end this dreamer
thing the language is absolutely absurd
propaganda it's exploitative it's it's
an euphemism that's being used to create
open borders here and we want dreamers
in America we want Americans to dream
again themselves here is I want dreamers
to come from the United States I want
the people in the United States that
have children I want them to have dreams
also we're always talking about dreamers
for other people I want the children
that are growing up in the United States
to be dreamers also okay he wants the
yeah that's perfectly fine who could
object to that the whole left objected
they said it was racist to say that we
want Americans to thrive that we want
Americans to do well and to be able to
dream that was considered racist how is
it racist because they call everything
racist and when everything's racist
nothing is racist right now president
Trump moderates that and says look just
overturn daca and we'll we'll even let
them stay I'm gonna put my cards on the
table we'll let the illegal aliens some
of whom
pushing 40 now will let them stay even
that is too much for the left even that
is so there's no conservatives
moderating that ain't going to happen
we've we've moderated enough pretty much
unsuccessfully at least in recent years
and how else would you like us to
moderate if we're not going to moderate
on policy then are you saying we need to
moderate on our language on our civility
we already did that we've we've done
that very well and I think that's a good
thing but you can't you're not gonna do
that anymore we've been respectful we've
gone after right-wingers who we find
distasteful the left never does that you
never hear about never Hillary on the
Left there's no significant movement of
never Hillary no they come together they
never police their own their own
ideologues so that that answer ain't
gonna work I mean that'll just push the
acceleration button on the on the
vehicle and we're gonna Corrine off into
a leftist nightmare how about moderation
from the left is that gonna work also
completely absurd I'll give you an
example up in San Francisco the new DA
of San Francisco jeiza boudin I'm
probably butchering that name but so
what chase' boudin is the new DA of San
Francisco and says that he will not
prosecute cases involving quote quality
of life crimes
those are his direct words quality of
life crimes meaning public urination
meaning shooting up drugs on the street
he says it he actually goes on verbatim
crimes such as public camping meaning
being a bum offering or soliciting sex
prostitution public urination blocking a
sidewalk etc should not and will not be
prosecuted now of course it should be
prosecuted because there is
self-government in San Francisco or at
least there used to be in there laws
against those things and it's this guy's
job to enforce the laws but he's not
going to do it because he's made himself
dictator of San Francisco so now he says
that he's not going to enforce these
laws one of what was the nicest cities
in America has become a public toilet
same thing in Los Angeles Los Angeles
just in Hollywood over here a woman was
a few months ago pulled out of her car
by a homeless person and he poured a
bucket full of human feces on her head
she's now going through psychological
counseling because about traumatizing
this was fortunately she didn't catch
any any physical diseases from it that's
what's happening in the cities right now
that's what's that's what the left is
campaigning on there it's not even like
it's that's just happening because of
the the maladministration and the the
bad unintended effects of their policies
they're actually campaigning on it the
got the DA of San Francisco is
campaigning on yes we're gonna have more
public urination yes we're gonna have
more homeless people living in squalor
on the street and you know what else
we're gonna have more drugs and
prostitution too yet that left is not
going to moderate guys ain't gonna
happen how about what happened up in
America's had in Canada a guy was fired
from his job for saying that we should
honor our veterans we'll get to that in
a second first I got to thank our
friends over at move mint you know that
the holiday season is fast approaching
Christmas is right around the corner and
you should probably not get caught two
days before Christmas not having bought
any gifts now fortunately movement will
make gift shopping very easily beautiful
curated gift boxes his and hers gift
guides and free and quick shipping right
to your door just in time for the
holidays you know last year I gave my
father a movement watch and he loves it
he wears it all the time and this is a
guy who wouldn't even wear a watch
before that so they they're really a
terrific sleek Styles I've gotten more
compliments on my movement watch than
any other watch I've ever had
they've got what they've got what I
would call retro futurist design
especially I've got the revolver Edition
which I think is their coolest looking
one but they've got a ton of stuff
they've got automatic watches and
they're just great they're designed
in-house super sleek clean and most
importantly they won't break the bank
movement watches start at just 95 bucks
clean design minimal and minimal minimal
list I would say really quality products
movement has sold almost 2 million
watches in over 160 countries it's just
guaranteed to land with whoever you're
giving it to big winner this holiday
season you can do that at movement 15%
off today you will get that I will give
that to you that is my Christmas gift
to you free shipping and free returns go
to movement dot-com MVM t-dot-com
/ noel scanner wles that is em VMT
dot-com they took away the vowels and
passed along the savings to you MVM
t-dot-com / Knowles canna wles and join
the movement so you've got the left
campaigning on turning our beautiful
cities into public toilets then up in
Canada and I this is the most recent
example but you've seen plenty of this
PC censorship go on in the United States
there's an NHL broadcaster Don Cherry
who for Armistice Day said that you know
as a day that Canada is honoring her
veterans that people should wear the
little puppies buy a poppy where a
little poppy on your lapel to remember
Armistice Day or to remember the
sacrifices made by Canadian veterans
during that first world war and he said
look it's very important to do this and
even as there's mass migration all over
the West including in Canada it's
important for new migrants to honor the
customs and traditions of Canada which
is now their adopted home country here
is what Don Cherry had to say you know I
was talking to a veteran I said I'm not
gonna run the poppy thing anymore
because what's the sense I live in
Mississauga nobody wears a very few
people wear pop poppy the downtown
trying to forget it downtown Toronto
nobody where's the poppy and I'm not
gonna wait says wait a minute how about
running it for the people that buy them
now you go to the small cities and you
know you know those the rolls unrolls
you people loved you you they come here
whatever it is you love our way of life
you love our milk and honey at least you
could pay a couple of bucks for poppies
or something like that these guys pay
for your way of life that you enjoy in
Canada these guys paid the the biggest
price anyhow I'm gonna run it again for
you great people and good Canadians that
bought a poppy I'm still gonna run it
anyhow love you for it he got fired for
those remarks does anybody actually
object to those remarks honor your
veterans and especially if you're a
recent immigrant you should be
especially grateful to this country
that's taken you in and done so much for
you if you were say a refugee
or just an economic migrant you should
be very very very grateful to the
country that took you in and you should
take part in their customs and
traditions and you should honor their
veterans who helped to build that
country totally unobjectionable stuff he
gets fired from its Sportsnet issues
this apology quote Dawn's discriminatory
comments are offensive and they do not
represent our values and what we stand
for as a network that was the president
of Sports Net we have spoken with Dawn
about the severity of this issue and we
sincerely apologize for these divisive
remarks he didn't say anything divisive
what he said was uniting uniting
Canadians including immigrants including
recent Canadians uniting all of them and
saying get behind these customs and
traditions and be grateful to your to
your people who went before you but
according to the left division is unity
and unity is division that left is not
going to moderate I mean a left that in
Canada is firing people for honoring
their veterans in America is protesting
the American flag on the Sports Network
same thing that left is not going to
moderate we can't it's wishful thinking
it's false optimism to say that it will
by the way in general moderation doesn't
usually serve anybody right you know I
always loved we were talking about
Dennis Prager earlier and we'll talk
about Dennis Prager movie a little bit
later as I was at the Hollywood premiere
last night Prager always says to his
guests when he's talking to people he'll
say I don't really care if you and I
agree probably we don't agree but we
don't need to pretend that we agree in
our conversation we just need clarity we
just need to be clear about where we
disagree so that we can understand the
issue what moderate middle ground can
there be between the left and the right
right now at this moment the left once
open borders at least the political left
the majority of Americans by the way
want radically lower rates of legal
immigration that's according to a
Harvard Harris poll that came out a year
ago but that's that's where you get kind
of what you would call populist
movements from the political left
however once open borders they've
advocated for it very openly at
Democratic presidential debates and on
the hill so you've got the left wanting
open borders the right wanting a
reduction in immigration so what's the
compromise we
in nearly two and a half million people
a year now or what we're gonna take in a
million and a half is that going to
appease anybody is that going to solve
the problem I don't think so
the left wants to erase your
constitutional rights the right wants to
keep your constitutional rights so
what's the middle ground you're only
going to sort of take away your right to
free speech you're only gonna sort of
take away your right to guns what that
doesn't solve anything that's know that
moderation there doesn't doesn't address
any issue and it doesn't please anybody
so I think we gotta throw moderation at
the window then one way that people want
to avoid the Civil War as that the
atlantic puts it one way that people
want to unite the country is they want
to return to the founding the founding
era if we could just go back to 1776
everything would be great that was kind
of the idea behind the Tea Party and it
was great you know it was I loved the
Tea Party I thought it was a terrific
movement tea parties gone why is the tea
party gone because it doesn't really
work it's kind of a charming and
beautiful idea and it works in short
spurts the Tea Party worked really well
from 2010 to like 2014 but it's not
sustainable in the long term
why not because it misunderstands what
tradition is tradition and conservatism
right conservatives we're trying to
conserve something is not about picking
some random date in history and saying
that's the date that we're all gonna
live in 1776 that's when history's gonna
stop
that's when fashions are gonna stop and
we're all just gonna wear those triangle
hats and buckle shoes and shoot muskets
and that's it no true conservative
nobody who has any conception of the
founding itself or not the founders
themselves wouldn't have wanted to do
that I mean that's kind of the argument
for getting rid of the second Amendment
that the left makes if they say those
founders couldn't imagine any world
outside of 1776 they couldn't imagine
any guns other than muskets
they were pretty smart guys they were
smarter than you and me they understood
that history moves on technology
advances the way that we conserve things
the way that we have a tradition is we
follow in this sort of unbroken line
throughout the ages and we preserve and
cherish those institutions which endure
the
tradition isn't some old thing that
happened 200 years ago the traditions is
the newest thing on earth because it's
endured
it's that lively it's that fresh it's
that renewing it's that innovating right
it sort of innovates in its own
durability it's kind of the same thing
with libertarianism and communism you
know at there people who love
libertarianism they say look if we could
all just agree to live in this
anarcho-capitalist environment without
any government then we'd all be happy
and say okay maybe that's true but
that's never going to happen in reality
that never has happened in reality
that's an ideological utopian pipe dream
it's kind of nice to have those
fantasies but it is a fantasy
same thing with communism the the left
will always tell you true communism has
never been practiced capital T capital C
with a trademark over the m okay maybe
it hasn't but maybe there's a reason for
that though because it's not practicable
it has no relation to reality
what's another solution one solution
that's being advanced by the right and
people in the center is to end
immigration just stop immigration right
now that's a real hard core policy
position right stop immigration then
we'll all learn to assimilate and we'll
get together and it'll be much much
better they think this would unite the
country it could help to reduce
immigration right a great reduction in
immigration would be popular and it
would it would help to assimilate people
who are already here but even that
solution could not work even that
solution is a pipe dream we'll get to
why in a second first speaking of safety
I got to get to our friends over at ring
you know how much I love ring and
especially this season especially as
Christmas is coming up this season can
be a whirlwind of deliberate ease and
visitors and family members who maybe
want to see and so you look on your ring
device and you say oh there's there's
grandma at the door oh come on in
grandma or maybe you look at your ring
device you say oh there's my
mother-in-law at the door everyone don't
move a muscle do not pretend you are not
here it is the best time of year to
upgrade your doorbell and keep an eye on
home no matter where the holidays take
you ring helps you stay connected to
your home from anywhere if there's a
package
delivery or surprise visitor you get an
alert you'll be able to see here and
speak to them all from your phone if
you're on the go this season I certainly
am I think I think most people are
heading to Grandma's house for dinner on
Christmas or going somewhere for
Thanksgiving whether it's across town
routes across the country you can check
in at any time for some much-needed
holiday peace of mind I love it actually
of an update I told you I give out my
ring ring devices to friends for their
housewarming so I had a couple friends
of mine I give them a ring device and
they were using it it really gave them
peace of mind because they thought
someone was trying to break in then they
looked on their ring and they realized
it was just a possum and so they kept
the possum they let the possum live
there then the possum had a little
possum baby but then they saw other
little animals like raccoons and things
on their ring device and so the baby
possum kind of disappeared and they
thought this story would have a pretty
bad end to it but they were checking in
on their ring device and they refined
this little baby opossum there's a happy
ending after all you too can have that
kind of heartwarming Christmas story or
you can use it more practically and make
sure nobody tries to rob you and you can
check in with the delivery guy as a
listener right now you have a special
holiday offer on a ring starter kit with
a ring video doorbell and
motion-activated floodlight camera the
starter kit has everything you need to
start building a ring of security around
your home no matter what the holiday
season brings with ring you're always
home just gonna ring calm / Knowles Cana
wles
that is ring.com / Knowles Skinner wles
additional terms may apply they always
do so this idea of looks stop
immigration and we'll just hunker down
and that will unite the country and
avoid the Civil War first of all the
left is pushing mass immigration and has
been for decades and decades that's the
problem that a lot of people especially
on the right don't understand but
there's another structural problem which
is that we actually can't turn off
immigration right now we can't do it
because our society is not having any
kids though they're not having very many
kids at least we are our birth rates are
way below replacement levels we're at
about 1.7 you need to get to about 2.1
or 2.2
for the population to sustain itself
it's not now there's a kind of irony
here which is that we kill a million
babies a year through abortion if we
just got rid of abortion and had those
million babies a year you would have no
problem you would have no population
shortfall and you would have no need for
this kind of immigration on the level
that we're seeing right now that is an
us problem that is a social and cultural
problem that's not a problem of just
lots of people trying to come to America
at the extremes of the immigration
debate and the immigration issue seems
to crop up a lot in all of this civil
war talk at the extremes of this debate
there becomes a debate over race at the
the I would say extreme left although
it's really become the mainstream left
there seems to be in antipathy for white
people meaning on the new york times
you'll see these stories about a
whiteness is terrible or you'll see
classes and workshops at colleges about
toxic whiteness and how terrible
whiteness is and so you have this racial
obsession from the left that you've had
for at least 60 years now i mean that
that is what identity politics is and
the left is what embraced it however the
fringe right not the mainstream right
but the fringe right also appears to
have an antipathy to people of other
races the very fringe right wants to
become some sort of white identitarian
movement and both of those things are
completely absurd now the left's is
absurd because the majority of America
is white so if you're gonna form a
movement that basically is antipathetic
to white people then you're gonna have a
problem winning any sort of hearts and
minds if you're in that country where
most people are white the rights the
very fringe rights obsession with race
is also absurd for a few reasons one
because there's not white ideological
solidarity and there never has been
white people are quite divided
ideologically okay the there's a real
irony here to this kind of white
identitarian politics because it
presumes that there is some sort of
pan-european solidarity
one need only crack the
spine of a history book of Europe to
find out there is not will not be and
never has been pan European solidarity
all the various nations of Europe have
spent most of history murdering each
other and at war with one another with
brief moments of partial unity that
doesn't make a whole lot of sense
it also doesn't make a lot of sense it
with this white racial politics focus
from the fringe right because America
has always been multiracial it began
when English pilgrims who had actually
moved to Holland came over to
Massachusetts and formed a very close
alliance with one Indian in particular
masa so at through the intercession of
Squanto this unbelievable Native
American who coincidentally spoke
English and then forged really
productive alliances with various Native
American tribes in the early and mid
17th century and then they imported a
black slaves from Africa and from the
very earliest days of this country you
had a lot of different ethnicities
nationalities races here together it
working together in working
relationships so the the idea of some
kind of white is the driven snow racial
politics in America just has never
existed and doesn't make a whole lot of
sense the other aspect of this is it's
blaming the wrong people it's blaming
the immigrants for mass immigration it
the immigrants are not the ones who
pushed mass migration it's leftists in
America specifically white leftists
specifically a white leftist named Ted
Kennedy if 1965 all right that is that
is that cannot be boiled down to race
it's an ideological question so then
we're left with a choice if we throw
away even that argument which is the
most sort of tangible issues argument
then we're left with a choice we can
debate the nature of the government
should the government get more involved
in social questions and moral questions
and religious questions even or should
it get less involved and just keep a
totally neutral stance
and simply let the culture and people in
their civic associations decide these
questions for themselves the right is
divided on this the left is not if we
have a civil war in this country it will
not be a war like 1860 it will not be a
war over a particular political issue
such as slavery which it was back then
if we have a war a civil war it will be
a religious war people are pretending
that we have religious neutrality in
this country a separation of church and
state people who don't understand what
that phrase meant when it was written
those people are kidding themselves we
do not have a separation of church and
state in this country we have a state
established religion here and that state
established religion is leftism and that
is the problem it's not in effect of
mass migration it's not in effect of
some university policy even it's not in
effect of some tax policy it's not an
effect of any of those particular
political issues it is the root cause of
it the civil war will be a religious war
and leftism
is a totalizing religion don't take my
word for it a Democratic sitting senator
mazie Hirono is making the point for me
she's admitting it we'll get to that in
a second we'll get to what that means
how we can fix it and we will get to
2020 because there is major major news
afoot a presidential candidate has
dropped out in 2020 it's breaking news
for many people it's breaking news that
this guy was running in the first place
plus news on the whistleblower plus I'm
gonna talk about the no safe spaces
premiere the Adam Carolla and Dennis
Prager movie which we went to last night
and it's a lot of fun we'll tell you
about the movie and we will tell you
when to go see it first you got to go to
daily wire.com
daily wire.com 10 bucks a month hundred
others for an annual membership you get
me at the end room Clavin show you get
the Ben Shapiro show you test questions
in the mailbag that's coming up on
Thursday you get to ask questions
backstage you get another Kingdom the
last and best season and you get the
left is tears tumblr
the leftist here's tumblr particularly
important when you're looking at the
2020 presidential race go to daily
wire.com we'll be right back with a lot
more
the root cause of this division is
religion is a religious division it's
the hard religion of the left and it's a
religious denial on the right the right
which wants to pretend that we don't
have any established religion or the
right that wants to pretend that
secularism and atheism is somehow value
neutral which it's not trust the left on
this when they admit it mazie Hirono was
talking specifically about global
warming and she said it's important for
people to think about global warming not
as a scientific fact but as a religion
for a lot of us
protesting marching that's not something
that we normally do but in what these
are times that call for us to do those
things that we believe in and to March
and not just to March
because that's important to show
solidarity but then to do those things
such as voter registration get people to
how to vote so that we can have people
here who truly are committed to human
rights environmental rights climate
change believe in climate change as
though it's a religion it's not a
science and all of the things that
remains to be done and there is a lot
that's yeah she's admitting it I've said
this many times I've said it on TV I've
said it in debates I've said it on this
show I've written about it global
warming is a religion it's part of the
left's religion and the left always
tells me that's a lie and then mazie
Hirono accidentally tells the truth it's
obviously a religion leftism broadly is
obviously religion it is a totalizing
worldview that encompasses all the
eternal questions it gives people
meaning it gives people a sense of the
beautiful it gives people a sense of
purpose it gives people an original sin
the original sin of privilege for
instance it gives people Redemption
Redemption and woke 'no sand public
apologies it is a religion and it's i
don't even blame them for having this
religion it's no coincidence that as
religiosity in the united states in
traditional religion christianity
judaism
that has declined adherence to leftism
has increased it was ever thus it was
always going to be that way I mean you
don't just see it in the global warming
example although the global warming
example is so clear because they
actually now have climate confessionals
and they sell indulgences in the form of
carbon tax credits so there you're gonna
really see it but you see it for
instance on gender ideology there was a
poll just came out from Rasmussen
Rasmussen tends to lean right the poll
shows that a slim majority of Americans
oppose allowing male to female
transgender athletes to compete in
women's sporting events meaning men who
are pretending to be women can they
compete in women's sporting events and
then almost inevitably beat them at them
because men are physically stronger the
good news is a majority of Americans
still think that's wrong the bad news is
it's only 51% 29% of Americans think
it's totally fine to let men compete
against women and beat them and 20% are
undecided but this is moving pretty bad
direction here and it's it's by the way
entering into the school systems now so
there was an organization that was I
think it's called LGBT questions or
something it's putting out of proposed
curriculum to teach elementary school
students very very young students this
gender ideology to indoctrinate them in
a completely unscientific gender
ideology that tells you that boys can be
girls and girls can be boys here's just
a clip from it
hi I'm meeting a sex educator I use the
pronouns she and her because I'm a woman
and when I was your age I used to be a
girl gender is how you feel on the
inside about whether you're a boy or a
girl a man or a woman if you're not
binary
feel like neither or both people can
also be fluid feel more like female
right male honest based on a different
day or time it's really individual
absolutely everyone born with a vulva is
a Crone - or false identifies not
everybody is sure and that makes sense
but our genitals actually don't
determine our gender so some people born
with vulvas and may boys so what I love
about this clip I mean it's a horrifying
clip but what I love about this clip is
they say so okay boys can't become girls
just by thinking it right all people who
are boys or boys right and how many
people think that and then all the kids
raise their hands because the kids they
don't know they don't know maybe you
know advanced calculus but they know
basic biological facts they say yeah
that's right boys are boys and girls are
girls they say actually that isn't true
so they're indoctrinated as kids younger
and younger they have to do it because
their religion of leftism is so
disconnected from reality then they go
on they have a person who's a woman who
had now identifies as a man telling
children that they can be whatever sex
they want to be I have been through the
spectrum if we were to say a spectrum of
like boys and girls I have been
everywhere in between I was born a girl
and then when I was two years old I told
my mom for the first time that I was a
boy and I think that I framed it I don't
remember it I've only been told stories
but I framed it because my brother's
middle name was the same as my dad's and
so I insisted that my middle name was
also the same as his but back in the day
there was no talk shows and there was no
internet there was no resources so she
just ignored it and then nothing
happened for many many years and then it
still took me a long time into my 20s
before I decided to transition but in
there I was a you know a tomboy if
that's what we say or like I was sporty
I'd short hair look at how exploited if
this is or look at look at all the
advocacy here this isn't just presenting
some facts to children it's not
presenting any facts for children's
presenting fantasy but the suggestion
here is look I was a tomboy maybe if
you're a tomboy
you're actually the opposite sex yeah I
had short hair maybe if you've got short
hair maybe you're the opposite sex it's
horrifying I mean this is it's
horrifying to subject children to this
kind of sexual confusion at such a young
age to subject them to such a bizarre
radical new ideology that has no basis
in science and it's only been around for
a few years but they're doing it they're
doing it because leftism ism is a
totalizing religion and this is this is
not just something that's neutral with
the neutral government the government is
pushing this on kids
why because education is inherently
intrinsically it coercive you don't you
can't just be educated by consent
because you're you're being taught a
curriculum right so you consent to go to
school but then you are taught from a
teacher who has a different power
dynamic than a student does and they're
teaching you something that's why you
have fears about political
indoctrination rather than proper
education this we have to acknowledge
that this leftism
is the state religion and we have to
acknowledge that America has a religion
that all societies have a religion you
know it's true in the First Amendment we
don't have any established particular
sect of religion there's no established
church right and that is forbidden by
the First Amendment rightly so but that
doesn't mean that there's no religion in
public life that's impossible and that's
certainly not what the founders thought
it just means that there's no official
American Methodist Church and the
official Church of America's Methodism
we're the official Church of America is
anglicanism or Presbyterianism at the
founding there was a national religion
that religion was a vague but shared
Christian religion and it was Protestant
and it was pluralistic and it was
tolerant in a made room for Catholics
and a made room for Jews but it was
clear there was this vague tolerant
religion then in 1962 long after the
founding and not that long ago but right
around when the whole country started to
lose its mind the Supreme Court outlawed
reading the Bible in schools that was no
longer permitted from the beginning of
the country until
1962 it was permitted and encouraged
just about everywhere and then that went
away because the Supreme Court decided
to rewrite the country also in 1962 they
outlawed prayer in schools so that kind
of national religion the vague tolerant
Protestantism went away as a result of
that people started to focus on what's
called the American civic religion you
know fireworks in the 4th of July the
idea of American nationalism the idea of
America's divine institution that
America is a sort of quasi religious
entity and that kind of dominates mid
20th century understanding of ourselves
all the way up at least through the
1980s that focus on American Civic
religion failed to particularly in
recent times in in light of the failed
interventions abroad we we tried to
plant american-style Madisonian
democracy in these deserts around the
world and it didn't work out the way
that many people told us it would work
out that's why I think so much of the
American Civic religion kind of lost
lost faith in itself and we lost faith
in it particularly in light of mass
migration if the American civic religion
were really a totalizing religion or a
sufficient religion then you could flood
the country with unlimited aliens or
illegal aliens or legal immigrants you
could have millions and millions per
year and they would simply assimilate by
divine Fiat or something but that's not
what happened and that's why the wars
abroad are such a touchy issue right now
it's why mass migration is such a touchy
issue is there something practical we
can do absolutely what we need to do
immediately is to reverse the decisions
that banned the Bible from schools and
banned prayer from schools not saying we
need to make it compulsory not saying we
need to make any of those things
compulsory but we need to permit it we
must encourage proper religious and
civic engagement we have to do away with
the lie that secularism is neutral
they're secularism is not neutral it is
atheistic and it is intrinsically
leftist we have to do away with the lie
that you can't legislate morality all
legislation is moral all laws are moral
because they draw on the moral law
that's obviously true and when you look
at issues like abortion it's true when
you look at tax rate
- because tax rates are talking about
property rights tax rates are talking
about the dignity of the human person
when you get down to the end of it
that's what we have to do I remember the
scene in Breaking Bad there's this scene
right after a big moment in the show and
the kids in the high school are at an
assembly and one of the girls says I
just I just don't know why God would
allow this bad thing to happen and the
principal cuts are often says hey hey
hey let's keep it secular as if
secularism we're neutral it's not it's
not neutral it's radical and it doesn't
help us to explain anything or to
understand ourselves or to live in a
harmonious society John Adams said our
country is built for a moral and
religious people the religion he was
talking about it's not leftism that's
the leftism is immorality and that's the
the religion that we're living in now
the creed of ignorance and the gospel of
envy as Winston Churchill called it we
need to acknowledge that religious
reality or we're not going to we're not
going to be able to avoid that Civil War
this is urgent now because censorship is
heating up okay the Trump election
bought us some time on this but it's
heating up right now YouTube just issued
a policy it hasn't even been been that
well publicized that says that YouTube
basically has the right to kill any
channel that it finds not commercially
viable so if YouTube is not making money
on your YouTube channel it reserves the
right to take away your YouTube channel
now most people don't make money on
their YouTube channels it's not going to
affect most people but what it's going
to do is in the run-up to the 2016
election allow the left to censor
conservatives because first what they do
is they cut down your reach of your
channel then they D monetize you and
then once they've demonetized you you're
obviously not making money they can
delete your channel altogether because
it's not commercially viable this is a
really tricky and dishonest way that
YouTube is trying to silence
conservatives it's all about 20/20 and
cutting off any momentum that that
conservatives on the right have right
now
now speaking of 20/20 before we go I do
have to point out major story a
candidate has dropped out of the 2020
race and it's a candidate you didn't
even know was running former South
Carolina Governor who left the gov
to go run away to Argentina with his
mistress and then ran for Congress and
got reelected mark Sanford has dropped
out of the race I'm not even going to
play the clip for you because you've
never heard him before and you're not
gonna hear him again so he's out the the
right wing challenges to Donald Trump
fall apart every day Hillary Clinton
wants to run again in an interview with
the BBC she's again opened up this
possibility that she's going to run she
said I say the same thing every time
people ask I'll do everything I can to
retire the incumbent that can be by
supporting those running I'm just
grateful for the opportunities I've had
a lot of pushing hard for me to run
again but I believe we have to keep our
focus on what it will take to get a new
president she obviously wants to do this
and maybe the opportunity is right for
her to get back into this race why would
she get back in because as much as the
right is divided the left is very
divided too they've had 25 candidates
for president they can't pick a single
one of them then a little preview on The
Whistleblower we'll get to this a little
bit more hopefully tomorrow there is now
a whistle blower blowing the whistle on
the whistle blower this whistle the
second whistle blower is filing a
complaint with the intelligence
community IG because the first whistle
blower is using his whistleblower status
to make money and raise funds on
GoFundMe so we've now got the whistle
blower on the whistle blower on
something that we already saw the
transcript for it is a total joke it is
a total farce as impeachment heats up I
think the Democrats are gonna get a lot
more than they bargained for they're
getting a lot more than they bargained
for because the right is not sitting
down we're not we're not giving up we're
not letting them run roughshod over us
and shut us up and kick us off of the
internet and kick us out of the
mainstream media and overturn the 2016
election we're not doing it we're not
doing it on campuses either I was at the
premiere last night of no safe spaces
which is Adam Carolla and Dennis Prager
is movie on the college censorship issue
it is really good I told them that I
since we're friends I would have told
him it was good even if it wasn't good
but there's this extra nice thing which
is that the movie is really really quite
good I highly recommend you go see it
it's shocking it was shocking even to me
and I live it not go to these guys
campuses and some of what you see in
that movie is so so terrifying it's
playing this weekend I think in Burbank
they're kind of doing a little bit of a
slow roll out and then it's gonna go to
a lot more theaters around the country
by the way there's a little Easter egg
you'll be able to see me in the movie if
you look very very closely so go check
it out we've got a lot more to get to I
don't know how we ran out of time like
this we'll have to get to all of it
tomorrow in the meantime I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Noel's show
see you then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boy
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director pavel y
douse key edited by danny D'Amico audio
is mixed by my core amina hair and
makeup is by joshua alvera and our
production assistant is Nick Sheehan the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19 on
the Matt Walsh oh we're not just
discussing politics we're talking
culture faith family all of the things
that are really important to you so come
join the conversation
you